our plan is clear is to fight corruption
well one of the people of level going to
get back I know we are very much we are
very much aware and committed to that
you have never letting me finish the
answer Hezbollah whether you like it or
dislike it represents a large component
of divine society even before the corona
virus pandemic Lebanon's economy was
plummeting through the floor decades of
catastrophic mismanagement and rampant
corruption the pushed almost half the
population into poverty joining me from
Beirut this week is the country's
foreign minister Nassif kitty as Lebanon
negotiates urgently for assistance what
guarantees can he give that his
government is any better than the
previous ones
[Music]
nassif Hitty welcome to conflict zone
thank you
two weeks ago your prime minister mr.
diem wrote an article in a US paper
pleading for international assistance
and blaming Lebanon's dire situation on
a combination of political mismanagement
and corruption why do you think that the
rest of the world with its economy in
tatters from the coronavirus should
simply hand you huge sums of money and
let you do the same thing all over again
well first and foremost because we're
not gonna do what happened before from
day one when we started working in this
government our plan is clear is to fight
corruption to go for structural reform
and and align structure reform it's not
minor reforms its basic reforms and the
philosophy of the economy not only in
the financial sector but the economy
which is the basic matter to address to
go more to go away from a rentier
economy as much as we can and go into
some productive sectors of the economy
agriculture economy the little
industrial thing and new technology
while maintaining of course our service
sector which is very important and
liberal economic model with respect to
be committed to transparency with great
respect these are just words and
intentions with that without a clear
plan to deal with your patronage ridden
public allow me if you allow me to
continue yeah but you can't judge of
course it's for you to judge the way you
like to say it of course and I have to
say it as we're saying it we starting on
this matter
we started with has been 100 days now of
course we're taken by the go feed 19
problem which is not an excuse but it's
a problem weighing heavily on us but
what I'm suggesting we're committed to
that matter this is why the word must
try us but I'm not saying to give us a
blank check what we have been saying at
what you have doing as a following we're
reaching out to all countries members of
international support group for Lebanon
to all international regional
organizations with which we're dealing
with cooperating on one hand
well as open to the civil society to
representatives of different intentions
I hear intentions your public sector has
been looted for decades by the same
sectarian powers that still dominate
this is what we're trying if you never
allow me to finish the phrase so I'm
listening to you now you go tell me what
we should do perhaps we can profit from
it I haven't finished the question
you think these warlords and power
brokers but you have never letting me
finish the answer you've been giving me
okay answer for a couple of minutes how
do you think do you think these warlords
and power brokers who control so much in
Lebanon will just sit around while you
shine a light on all their dirty
dealings and then they'll just say sorry
and hand back all the billions that
they've stolen you really think that's
gonna happen we are not gonna think so
thanks for putting this question we know
it's an uphill struggle we know it's a
key challenge and you have to stand up
to the challenge or fail I know the
difficulties I fully agree with you
about the seriousness of the challenges
about how happy they are weighing on us
since years but we have to come out with
an answer otherwise will not be taken
the road that we promise to take that's
a very important matter I fully agree
about the challenges the nature of the
challenges the magnitude of the
challenges but you have to come out with
an answer to these challenges and create
a sort of rupture with the past and yet
on a start on a new foot you're your
country's record doesn't inspire
confidence does it since the Civil War
Lebanon has promised four times to
reform in return for food it seemed sure
you enjoy thinking about the past
I'm telling you about the future if you
want to go into the past we can have a
lesson in history now
yeah but why should anyone trying to
tell you we know the stories we learn
the lessons we are trying and we're
telling the international community look
as a look at us and let's see if we
succeed we are we are we are planning to
succeed we're committed to success
because we have to save our country
again I agree with you about your
description of the situation which I
already know we all we all know and
again I'm saying it's a major challenge
let's see for you if you can succeed and
facing up to it and this
the challenge that you are taking on us
is to succeed this matter with the
cooperation it's our primary
responsibility as the Bonnies government
it said not an easy matter I fully agree
with it's a very difficult matter
because of this well-established well
entrenched system that you rightly
described and with which I fully agree
with you but this is the only road that
you have to take to create a rupture of
the past the challenges are very
important very deep but we have to take
this is the only available road to get
out of this messy situation yes I
understand what you're saying but it
doesn't help when the team that you sent
to talk to the IMF figures from the
presidency the Finance Ministry central
bank prime minister's office they
present conflicting views about what
needs to be done your own officials
don't even agree on what should be done
hardly surprising when they come from
different sectarian factions so if this
represents well broome that completely
what you say sure we are I'm telling you
we're coming out of a very difficult
situation we are developing a common
policy again we admit it's not an easy
matter but we are progressing on this
matter
and engaging into this road that you
have to take the negotiations with the
IMF I understand the problems very well
of political sector ISM and Lebanon the
impact of it on the system all the
problems that has it has created for
four decades now but we have to try to
move out gradually as much as we can out
of this system and focus on creating and
consolidating state institutions I'm not
saying it's an easy task but I'm saying
this is the only way in order to salvage
the country
mr. Haiti the fact is that you're
drowning in disunity as you have done
for decades and the people know it you
just look at the very public fight
between your prime minister and the
governor of the central bank
these are arguably the two most
important people in Lebanon at the
moment and they're slugging it out in
public as the country's economy goes
into meltdown and your currency falls
through the floor what does that tell
the rest of the world this very public
fight between these two extremely
important figures well
there were some differences of course
but now we're working out in harmony
developing a position represented by the
government by the Prime Minister and the
government on trying to project you know
different steps in a strategy of
negotiations with the IMF you talk about
harmony in we're aware of the past
problems and so I say again very much
aware of you talk about harmony but even
the back trying to agree on your rescue
package do they and they're the heart of
your crime well I am saying trying to we
are we are working on developing and
consolidating a policy on that matter I
am very much aware of the Banking
Association position of what the
governor of a central bank has said but
we are developing a position different
assessments to reach well developed
position official position which is the
position of the government to negotiate
on to me the basis of the negotiations I
never suggest that nobody would suggest
that it's an easy matter we're coming
out of a very messy situation the
situation is still difficult
economically with its social and other
implications in the country but this is
a road to which you are committed which
is to be to go into real change real
reforms and let's wait and see for you
as you know concerned observers if you
succeed or if you don't succeed we we
draw the lessons of the past that you
rightly described and you have to get
out of you know of that situation that
existing that existed in the past and
that had very dramatic effects on the
Lebanese economy and be a nice polity in
general not only politics mr. Haiti
might have been a good idea if you'd
consulted the banks on the rescue
package hardly a brilliant move not even
consulting not to interrupt you we have
thank you for the advice but we do have
consultations we're all engage in
consultations to strengthen the official
policy of the country for negotiations
and for the strategic planning of
tomorrow you tried cross-party talks
with other political factions at least
five parliamentary blocks
coated your talks saying they didn't
want to be made scapegoats for the
government's past failings again that
hardly inspires confidence of the
international community does it to see
that Lebanon is as fractured we're open
to discussion sure we are open for let
me give you an example at the last
meeting hosted by the prime minister at
the Sarai with the members states and
organizations of the said group we
invited as the bonney's government for
different NGOs very qualified NGOs among
them research centers and groups to
prevent their views and that consider
this is very important because they
presented a view or views that are not
official government views just to inject
more ideas and more you know creative
thinking in order to develop more or
stronger policy in terms of the
salvation of the country so we're open
up to that as I started telling you we
open up internally to different factions
we look we extend our arms so anybody
would like to discuss we ask people to
come and discuss different political
sensibility is different protein groups
are welcomed to suggest what they're to
suggest we want to have a national
dialogue they all come in all
comprehensive national dialogue with
with representatives of different
sectors of the economy of the societies
of the civil society on one hand I am as
well as on the other hand with countries
which are supportive of Lebanon what you
are saying we are not saying we have a
we have a plan with a capital P take it
or leave it
the main ideas main out you've had fresh
violence you've had fresh violence in
the streets in May and it's clear that
you're not the government people wanted
you talked about consulting civil
society the beirut modernity civil
society group described your cabin I
never know that you're speaking for the
people I accept but this is can I can I
can tell you what the people say the
governor that the people wanted yes yes
I'm insane imagine a civil society group
described your cabinet as an insult a
provocation of the people and a disdain
for their dignity that's a far cry far
cry from the salvation okay I got
I got your message I got your message I
got your message if you give me one
second I respect all views those who are
against us from point one before the
government was formed and when the
government is form and we are extending
our arms to all of those to come and
discuss and present their views and
ideas we need a national dialogue in
order a constructive national dialogue
so those who criticize us we respect
their criticism and we are asking them
to come and discuss with us and say how
could we develop a national salvation
plan you let's talk about the elephant
in the room Hezbollah you may not be a
hezbollah government you've said you're
not a hezbollah government but they were
certainly the
Midwife that assisted at the birth of
this government let's also be clear that
Hezbollah has taken we have many
midwives in the birth of this government
with all due respect to your view I'm
telling you have many midwives I'm using
the same term and we won't have as as
representative as possible a government
we have and in this matter may I just
finish my question if you allow my
English my question has listening
hezbollah has also taken part in
previous Lebanese governments that have
so catastrophically mismanaged the
country in years gone by I'm asking how
does that qualify Hezbollah to become
part of the solution now well Hezbollah
whether you like it or dislike it
represents a large component of the main
society it's a main political party
political actor and Lebanon and
everybody is welcome to join and help us
and this whether directly being involved
directly or supportive or not supportive
of the government let's see for the
observers internal observers and
external observers like you sir if we
succeed you you say this and I hear what
you say why should the West lift a
finger to help a government that's
effectively being constructed by
Hezbollah which is widely viewed around
the we are math instructors or
contractors what you think is a port of
use it's not absolute reality
what you say is a point of view you are
yes you have I'm telling can I can I
answer you would you give me a second
thank you I'm saying I am say which
terrorist organization Hezbollah is
widely seen around the world as a
terrorist Valdez analyze a ssin it has
not seen around the word it's considered
by some but it is not what this some I
don't agree with this view you might
disagree ideologically politically
strategically with the Lebanese
political party ellaby's National
Resistance movement that's your right to
do so but it's image represent a major
component of the Lebanese society social
component and political component what
I'm saying take us to test as a
government and telling our Western
countries with to which we are committed
to develop the best out of relations
culturally politically socially
economically strategically with the
Western countries were very close to
most of those countries we have very
good relations which we want to develop
to deepen strengthen and enlarge these
Western countries take us to test and
about what we are doing what we are
planning to do not about what is said
here or there or about any ideological
sloganeering or ideological views well
let's just look at some of the specifics
that Hezbollah are accused of Britain
says that the organization continues to
amass an arsenal of weapons in Lebanon
in direct contravention of UN Security
Council resolution 1701 and 1559 putting
the security of the region at risk they
also support terrorism in Iraq and the
Palestinian territories
do you approve of those actions what you
call terrorism in Palestine is national
liberation movement Israel is a
terrorist State and Israeli policies are
terrorist policies of occupation of
wanting to you know just destroy the
national identity of a people of wanting
to serve of international and law of
human rights of self-determination
principles that's a terrorist policy
conducted publicly by Israel officially
by Israel so we are committed to peace
we are committed to other Peace
Initiative and the Arab
allow me to finish we're committed to
Arab the Arab Peace Initiative that's
based entirely on UN Security Council
resolutions voted by the first and
foremost by the five permanent members
and supported by the international
community so let's see who is conducting
terrorist policies here and there with
all the respect you could this you could
have a difference and I respect the
difference that you have with any
political parties in Lebanon or
anybody's foreign policy but what you
are saying here to rest and friend
friends take us to tests help us engage
us in a dialogue and a comprehensive
dialogue about how we are planning to
move forward to just get Lebanon out of
this messy situation the instability of
Lebanon addressing the instability and
creating a societal stability in Lebanon
is first and foremost the responsibility
of the Bonnies people but it's also in
the interest of the region and it's an
interest of the millennial region and of
the international community we are open
to all ideas critical ideas
comprehensive ideas about a particular
point or other things to discuss with us
we're very much open to dialogue we are
reaching out to everybody to dialogue we
accept criticism we welcome criticism we
want to discuss and try to get out of
this situation with respect if you don't
address the accusations that are made by
Western governments against Hezbollah
you're never going to inspire confidence
in the Western appreciation resolution
now to give you my gut your point
that means accusations are not realities
with all due respect to everybody they
come from some pretty how are you
expected governments absolutely and with
we have very good relations and we want
to develop these relations with the West
Western Europe with us we're committed
to develop and to discuss in openly and
to find common ground with these
governments and of these countries we
are very much we had we always had good
relations and you want to develop
furthermore these relations and when
Hezbollah is accused of terrorism you
turn around and simply accuse Israel of
terrorism how helpful do you think that
is to your call of course well this is
not to my cause as Hezbollah in Lebanon
is a resistance movement
fighting under the ban is it was
fighting on the banished territories you
might disagree or agree with its
policies I'm talking about the bonney's
government not about the policy of one
particular party but when we are
mentioning Israel Israel is still
occupying Arab land Palestinian lands
Syrian lands and Lebanese lands Israel
is trying to to destroy entirely the
Palestinian national identity at the
moment when we are committed entirely to
a peace process based on UN Security
Council resolutions and on principle and
rules of at a national law so tell me
who is conducting a terrorist policy and
the Arab Peace Initiative adopted since
2002 we call for a comprehensive peace
that addresses all tracks and all
dimensions of the conflict to turn the
page and create a peaceful Middle East
in which Israel could exist within 67
borders based on the UN Security Council
resolutions that were adopted by the
international community
not by Lebanon and the Arab countries
that's our commitment and clear
commitment so anyone who would like to
address terrorism or to fight radicalism
in the region must address the basic
roots of radicalism and terrorism in the
region of whatever you call terrorism
respecting international law respecting
UN Security Council resolution this is
where the issue must start and this is a
scenic one on condition to establish a
new Middle East based on cooperation and
leading to prosperity sir mr. et are you
prepared to subject Hezbollah to the
kind of scrutiny that might show where
their funds and weapons have been coming
from and where they're going are you
prepared to challenge Hezbollah to be
transparent its parent the government
the state of allow me to finish the
state of Lebanon decides what would
happen on its own territories we have a
sovereign decision I respect that you
disagree with us but we set the rules in
our country we set the criteria and
we're willing to discuss with anybody
anything of common interest we're very
much open to our Western friends I keep
telling you we have the best of
relations we might have differences with
certain government I took one point of
time we need to address this difference
these differences and find common ground
to work together well the record doesn't
inspire confidence
because look how Hezbollah behaved in
2008 when they didn't like the
government actions against them and when
the government attempted to remove
Hezbollah yes we are discussed we could
I finish the question
I respect your views though I might
destroy finish the question of Lebanon
yeah my point is that in you but but
when you look at the way Hezbollah
behaved in 2008 when they didn't like
government actions then the attempt to
remove their corrupt airport officials
and close down their illegal
communications they seized parts of
Beirut by force and brought them to a
virtual standstill that's what happens
when you challenge Hezbollah who says
that isn't going to happen again well
wait and see we are in a different
situation you presented a political
assessment of a political security
conflict at that time I respect your
views there are different views on that
matter I might agree or disagree with
you this is beside the point but we are
looking to the future we are looking
today to the future so let's see how
things will develop as a government
we're very much committed I'm not
telling you we don't have many
challenges internally and externally
we're very much committed to get Lebanon
out of the situation because this will
serve the stability of the country first
and foremost but also it will serve the
interests of all those would like to see
stability in the region when are you
going to stop cracking down on people
who are exercising their right to free
speech Human Rights Watch said in March
that we are cracking down on people sir
the that we always condemn certain
misuse or excessive use of force
sometimes in the street we are committed
to the right of each and every
individual each and every Lebanese to
demonstrate and the street and to engage
in dialogue an open dialogue and
discussion that's not borne out by
reality humans or any will finish we
can't then any
violence we condemn any act of violence
of course and we said that many times
committed against peaceful demonstrators
who are expressing very legitimate
demands and requests for change
Human Rights Minister Human Rights Watch
said in March there'd been a spate of
prosecutions against activists and
journalists who've criticized government
policies is that how you meet the
people's aspirations by cracking down on
them prosecuting and I I really don't
understand your generalization and
you're making statements as if they are
with all due respect any absolute
realities you're presenting a point of
view based on a fact that could be
interpreted and misinterpreted there is
no perfect society and no perfect
institution in each every country and
the word so basically if certain acts
which are unacceptable were committed
and acceptable according to our laws we
condemn these acts and we did it many
times nobody is saying that there is a
perfect situation but we are committed
to that and every time that we see
something happening like you what you
describe we try to correct that matter
we're committed to do that and we
welcome criticism of that matter sir how
long do you expect the people to wait
for these rights that you're promising
these reforms that you're promising the
end to corruption and back our looted
money give us back our looted money this
is what they say when one of the people
of level going to get back I know we are
very much we are very much aware and
committed to that it's not that
government that looted the money before
it's not this government that created
the situation that was before but
however we are committed to do all what
we can without friends again saying
inside and outside reaching to everybody
in order to get out of this vicious
destructive circle that Lebanon found
itself in I understand the very
legitimate frustration as well as the
very legitimate demands of the Lebanese
population of which I'm a member I'm
alive any citizen before being 11 is
official we understand these problems we
have to get together and try to get out
of this very difficult situation at
least you have a commitment and the
clarity the
we need to get out of this difficult
situation Nassif Hickey
thanks very much for being on conflict
zone thank you thank you very much sir
it's a pleasure thank you have a good
day
[Music]